how do you change an entire industry for
Jeff Bezos and his new grocery store of
the future
Amazon go it's a three-part process in
no particular order part one make a
video with over seven million views
Amazon's YouTube video is a bit of
utopian science fiction a vision for
what the future of grocery shopping
could look like an almost completely
frictionless consumer experience in
which you walk in grab what you want and
go the marketing here is extremely
important I think notice that Amazon
dropped this video like Beyonce drops a
surprise album and they made sure to
disable the comments and decline to take
questions about the concept from
journalists for the time being the point
is to let the idea just stay in the
public's mind letting us internalize the
ease and stress-free environment of our
future grocery stores this
internalization the hope goes will
flower into an expectation an
expectation is a very powerful force
that can move markets this potential for
change is crucial for the second
important thing part to get the patents
in 2013 and 2014
Amazon filed two patents that describe
most of the advanced technology we're
seeing inside the Amazon go store the
first call detecting item interaction
and movement describes a system for
tracking removal or placement of items
at inventory locations just like you saw
in the video using a variety of sensors
and cameras with object recognition
software the second expands on this
concept covering the payment of items
when you leave a designated area now
both these patents were filed primarily
for use in Amazon's warehouses but even
then they were putting in little hints
about their longer-term goals don't
think I don't see what you're doing what
are we doing Reuben
part three prove then wait once Amazon
creates the expectation for a customer
experience defined by technology that
they own the logical thing to do would
be to start building the Amazon ghost
stores you're likely to see Amazon start
doing that once they fix all the bugs
with their beta location in Seattle but
I think this obscures the much bigger
fish that Amazon is trying to catch here
to understand what I'm talking about you
have to look at another part of Amazon's
business Amazon Web Services the massive
cloud computing juggernaut that as of
2016 is the most profitable segment of
Amazon's entire business basically years
ago Amazon built an online
infrastructure to host and organize its
own site and then they realized that
they could take this technology and
license it to other companies from this
Amazon collects billions and fees the
internet as you know it wouldn't exist
without Amazon Web Services Netflix NASA
reddit the Obama campaign Pinterest and
the CIA are all hosted on its servers
and a lot more it's a business that's
growing fast and it's ten times the size
of its next 14 competitors combined it
was Brian Romilly the payments expert
who pointed me in the direction of
Amazon Web Services and and once you
learn that business model it's easy to
predict where Amazon is heading they
want to combine their patents with
marketing that creates this expectation
of a frictionless shopping experience
then they'll build a number of stores to
prove the concept by the time they have
a few hundred and operation the amount
of refined targeted data that they'll be
able to acquire on customers will make
the model irresistible
mr. yakamoto welcome back to the gap now
this is sort of tank tops workout for
you at that point Amazon just has to
wait supermarket chains nowhere near
capable of retrofitting their stores
with this kind of tech we'll have one
shiny place to turn for all their needs
and just like it does with its web
services Amazon will license like crazy
with their eyes toward dominating not
just supermarkets but the entire retail
universe a 25 trillion dollar industry
in the US alone
in other words Amazon Go is just the
beginning
[Music]
hey everybody thanks for watching
happy holidays I hope that you're with
people that you love this holiday season
the nerdfighter is like insanely close
to a million subscribers which is
messing with my head a little bit but if
you want to help me get there you can
subscribe to the channel by clicking
this box that I've set up right over
there that's a huge milestone for me
2016 has been the best year of my life
in huge part thanks to you guys and
everybody who watches the show everybody
who's come on to the show this year and
has really made this this project
something really special thank you so
much you're the best fans ever I'll see
all of you next Wednesday